hello welcome back to another tutorial
on C++ this one's gonna go a little bit
of a different direction
but as things start to get more
complicated and maybe you're working on
your own stuff there's something that
new coders really should be doing or
should at least know about so this
tutorial is not gonna be necessarily so
much about the code is more about
handling your projects no matter how
small or how whatever you think they are
you should be saving your projects and
as you edit and update them you should
be saving all versions and the way
people used to do this the old way is
they would just make multiple folders
and lots of copied files but you don't
need to do that anymore and the reason
is there's this code there's this
website called github so it's version
control there's other versions of this
there's also bitbucket and there's I
don't know I think it's one called
subversion there's a few others but
github seems to be the the biggest most
recognized one and if you ever want to
get a job in code you're gonna need to
know this if you ever are doing your own
projects and want to invite friends to
help you or whatever maybe you're gonna
need to know this this is really there
okay you just have to know this there's
no getting around it and for some people
that's really intimidating but it's way
easier than C++ so if you're gonna learn
C++ you might as well get this along the
way and this will actually help a lot
because you can go look at other
people's public code and and learn a lot
here too
and now when I first started learning
github I was at university and no it
seemed like nobody else was interested
in github I would seem to be the only
one of my classmates that was like on it
everybody else was just like confused
and unwilling to learn about it and that
kind of baffled me cuz when I did my
research about how people handle their
versions
code this was the answer and you know
being a school with a bunch of coders I
expected that people would be interested
in that sort of thing but nobody was and
I think the reason was people were
already so busy with their classes they
were really intimidated by it and I
didn't want to do stupid stuff and make
embarrassing mistakes and reveal them to
the world when they were learning and
you don't have to worry about that
because you can make all of your
repositories of code private you there's
no reason to ever make them public if
you don't want to so you can mess up as
much as you want and nobody's gonna know
what you and that's that should get rid
of that whole stress so beyond that I am
not really sure why people were very
unwilling to learn it but if you don't
you're hindering yourself significantly
so that's why I'm putting it in here in
the C++ series because I think it's that
important I was considering talking
about arrays and data types but you know
what I think get up more important than
that at this point and not everybody's
gonna agree with that but I think it is
so cygwin you can install get on cygwin
and I've already done it you run the
cygwin installer and do it there's
versions of a github all all over the
place but what we're gonna do in this
tutorial is basically take this code
we've been working on and put it all up
on github and I have a little code tech
and tutorials repo along with a bunch of
other random ones so when you log into
github or go make an account on github
you'll get a that you'll get a create a
repository button and you can you just
go click that create a new one and you
give it a name and I'm gonna call this
tutorial calculator you get a
description if you want as says optional
public private I'm going to leave it
public but if you don't want other
people see in your code and just just
backup for your own purposes you can
make it private
have as many private ones as you want
the only stipulation that github has on
that is if I think it's three or more
people are working on the code you need
to have a paid account for four private
repos so basically if you're a business
because it's you and two other friends
you're fine but you go to three or four
other friends then you might have to
start paying because you're basically a
business that point however that doesn't
mean you can I mean there's still ways
of sharing it and forking but that's a
little more advanced so one one of the
things that you'll notice about github
is it once a dot git ignore and a
license license is sort of optional when
you're starting out your codes not I
would do it anyway but you also need a
readme
so readme get ignore so we're gonna go
ahead and make those and I'm just gonna
do touch I'll do all the lowercase
readme dot MD for markdown
these are markdown files and I also want
to touch a dot get ignore and I want to
explain a little bit about what a kid
ignore is I get ignore is just a plain
text file has a dot in front of it
because it's a hidden file and it
basically tells github which files to
ignore because we don't want to upload
its actual executable we only want to
upload the code because if someone else
downloads is executable they're probably
on a different operating system and it's
not gonna run they need to compile it
anyways and this is way larger than all
of our code files so you want to
basically put stuff that you don't want
to be up on gift github that's in your
folders in this kid ignore so we're
gonna go ahead and do that and in fact
I'm gonna show you a little trick thing
see ya it's public initialize so this is
just gonna be fully blank I'm not adding
any of this stuff and it tells you a
little bit of information the very first
time you do it about
how to add the files so I'm gonna go
over all this you can you can follow one
of these you're not necessarily gonna
need all these but basically we're gonna
do a push to push our code up there and
that's that's really gonna be the big
thing and there's also well I'll walk
you through it
let's just let's go ahead and add some
stuff to her get ignore that we know we
don't want to put up on github so I'm
going to open visual studio code in the
way at the bottom right is get it up
here I'm gonna make a little bit larger
so I'm gonna type code dot dot slash go
back a directory and then new code and
now what this command does is it opens
Visual Studio code on this folder so
this is everything in the folder thank
you welcome
and you'll notice Visual Studio code
does have a source control tab and I
think I turned mine off because I like
using the command line but you can do
all this github stuff right within your
editor and you don't need to do all the
command line stuff and there's also
other programs that will help you along
with this so you don't necessarily need
to know all these commands you can just
get a program that handles it or use
Visual Studio codes even Visual Studio
Community Edition has it too so it's
it's not gonna be too bad I learned on
the command line with git so I'm just
used to it that way but I definitely
have appreciation boy of being built
into editors too you see I forget where
I turned it off I think it was somewhere
in properties or under extensions I
turned it off but yours will probably be
on because it defaults to on and it'll
once you have initialized your directory
as a github directory as a git directory
it'll start showing up on your little
project here so I've got my get ignore
I'm going to open that by clicking it
and I'm just gonna add starred idea
see and the star is a anything in dot
exe is well dot exe so that's gonna
ignore this file so that ones in there
and other things we're gonna want is
we're gonna start our files so they're
gonna be our object files now there's a
bunch more and you can go on google and
type get ignore for c++ and find pretty
much every every line you'd ever want
for c++ to add to yours if you think
you're gonna be you on your project for
a while but for now I'm just gonna have
these two lines on my kid ignore cuz I
know for sure that those are in this
particular project well the dotto
actually isn't but it could be if we do
any more work on it the dot exe
definitely is also if you're on Linux
rather than it being a dot exe you'll
see it as a dot dot help so I'm gonna
add that as well just for the Linux
users out there and also if you get a
crash and your program does a core dump
you okay to dot dump file so I'm gonna
add that as well cuz we don't want to
upload our dump files so those four are
some pretty standard ones there I'm
gonna go ahead and close that and now
I'm gonna look at my readme
now you read me displays on your project
and github so you want basically want to
have a little explanation of what this
is tutorial series I don't know what to
play year I might link my channel or
something calculator built on tutorial
series or code tech and tutorials
YouTube channel that'll be good enough
might a little more info and that's just
a plain line you can also I'm not gonna
talk about markdown syntax of a few
things I want to say here but it's sort
of like an HTML esque markup language so
I'm gonna make a header here just called
simple calculator so that'll be a big
header thing and Visual Studio Oh Visual
Studio code also has this awesome thing
for markdowns where you can open a
preview to the side so I'm gonna click
that and there it is that's what it's
about what it's gonna look like on you
on github when it comes up on github and
that's gonna be enough for the readme
you just should have something otherwise
it's it uh I don't know it'll look
really plain they're they're old make
file ok everything else is fine here
we've still got all these files here and
I think we're good there we got our get
ignored filled out we got to read me
filled out we could add a license I
don't know what dad for license honestly
right now but I'd recommend doing a
little research adding a license file do
new file license and you can basically
go google code licenses or something
like that there's a there's a bunch of
different one and there's so much to say
about it that I really don't want to get
into it here and nor do I had no quite
enough to really say much without
without doing some research but being in
search something like this COEs lights
and search choose a license and there we
go
my software isn't a project they're
licensed for that so I'm not really sure
which one so and it tells you what
happens if there's no license I don't
really want a license on this so cuz
it's just whatever maybe I'll add one at
a later date if it matters but okay well
enough about that so let's go ahead and
get this up to get up so I've already
created the repo called soryo calculator
so if I go back here I'll see all my
repos I got an old one called lambda
from an older video I did about lambdas
and now I've got this one and it tells
you stuff about it you can go click on
it and there we go
so go ahead and we'll go ahead and
follow these steps from the command line
so what I'm gonna do first thing well
this first line tells you to create a
readme we've already got files created
so we're not gonna worry about this
whole step of creating something we're
just gonna do giving it get in it can't
talk
alright so we you could start from your
root folder and you just type that
directly and this will initialize your
folder as a as a git folder and it lets
dog get in there then it put some basic
information and tells tells things like
your editor that it's that's ready for
github and you want to add your files
now this is where it might get a little
unintuitive cuz basically it doesn't it
doesn't just scan your folder and know
about everything automatically some
programs may do that but um if you're
just doing it command-line you actually
have to tell it to add files to the
upload stuff so when you do a git add
and if you do a dot it just does
everything and now when it does
everything it does check your git ignore
and it doesn't put in any of these so
and so with this dye in meaning
everything it's gonna mean everything
but the stuff and you're getting more so
I'm gonna go ahead and do that and now
we've got them all added so the next
thing it says is commit so when you add
a file you want to commit it and put a
message with it so committing is it's
basically just saying um it's ready to
go out so add it's like prepared and
I'll just think of it as like sending
mail out to the post office so hiding it
is like repairing your mail like you
know sealing up your letter committing
it is like it's like I don't know taking
it to the mailbox I guess and the remote
is where you want to send it to so
remote add origin and then the address
so this is where you send it to so we
are gonna do this commit get commit and
it commits everything that's currently
added and I'm just gonna call my commit
this - mmm stands for message I'm gonna
call it an it and then it gives me a
little info about what I just did
created all these files cool so now I
want to add this origin to tell it where
to push it to because so far I've only
typed getting it if I keep saying it get
it get in it get ad and get commit like
there's nothing here that tells it where
to sexually send this so that's the
point of this remote add origin as it
tells it to send it to my github this
user this
repo so it has to know that somehow if
you drop something in the mail with no
address to send it to they're gonna be
just really confused this is the same
way as I've I tried to push this up it'd
be like what are you talking about an
apple that says no configure push
destination so so let me go ahead and
yeah I'm gonna copy this origin and
paste it over here and now I push ship
work I'm gonna copy that paste it over
here push it and it's gonna ask for my
username and password that's the default
oh I'm gonna make sure I get this right
okay so I'm on there as my real name
this is just one of my little side side
repo things so that's why I gotta do it
as my real name I don't have multiple
plugins this is still under my main log
and it's just a free what they call it
it's just like a organisation I believe
so you can make organizations to which
is what business is typically do and
then they invite individual users to
work on their organization so that's
kind of point of doses so now I've gotta
go get my password so I'm gonna do that
on my other monitor and that's what I'm
doing right now disregard and I'm gonna
paste it in here you can't see it but it
is in there it's smart enough to hide it
and there it is it says writing pushing
we got a success no error now and would
refresh this will see that there's now
all our code here
so anytime you make changes you do a new
commit and a new push and that's the
very basics of it I'm getting started
and then any at any point you can go to
github and look at your history so if
you click on a file you'll have a
history that way if something goes
drastically wrong you can always go back
to an old version that's the whole point
of this and it also gives you the
freedom to change your code to play with
stuff to test things out with no worries
because worst case scenario you got your
old versions thank you for watching this
tutorial hopefully it helps you get
comfortable and used to to github and
realize how important it is and we will
continue with our normally scheduled c++
tutorials and a day or so take it easy
and keep on coding and don't forget to
give this video a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it I always forget to say that
not a very good self-promoter but it
does help help me out helps my videos
get recognized and I appreciate all you
guys and I'll see you later